loud clap powerful clap series of
clap burdock
preventive strike of the continuum pre-emptive
rebuff to greece as a gesture of
goodwill hello my name is vitaliy gordienko
and i'm the author of the youtube channel behind him film
mania evita par i will often
come here for hours and here to the south rainero and today we'll
talk about nova again  unofficially, the
terminology in Russia is still tacking the
truth about the terrible camp of speeches in Russia
in terms of peeping tusks and sometimes
forcibly absurd phrases of them you are a
crusade comedy blogger this leader food
could period 7 in order to reduce
economic problems through the imposition of
sanctions all coffee and paraski  then the joints and the
cute and well, the sound of the Russians and c
sound our view of the cockpit drops, because, too,
let's go through them to hate the
terminal and military special operations, which
essentially means a full-scale in
tornan ottawa we are less than ukraine
protection of people vladimir putin announced the
start of a special military operation in the
donbass
we have decided to conduct a
special military  f operations the
armed forces of the russian federation
continue a special operation in
ukraine an accessible term we have
cotton the Russians c will have fish
[music] the
walls of the window trembled then social
networks kirovites actively discussed the
loud bang over the city
they took other settlements in the afternoon around
noon
around the village, making
it shorter from there, I personally video how
it was initially whistling, then there was a clap and
then the jiva started, I already saw
around which one it broke into
exploded, how I didn’t kill almost all the
craft with fragments stolen don’t let me
killed us neo-Nazis Bandera not he
on valuable mystical battalions c they have
Ukrainians ki want gets at the cathedral did not
hold the main clash of the
Russian army what was expected is
happening not with regular units of the
armed forces of ukraine with
nationalist form the honor of the
inhabitants of ukraine
intimidated many duped in nazi
nationalist propaganda
and someone, of course, deliberately followed the
path of Bandera’s other
Nazi henchmen who
fought on the side of Hitler during the Great Patriotic War,
and the fact that we are fighting against him
by the Nazis renders the very course of hostilities
nationalist and not Nazi
formations among them there are
foreign mercenaries in  including from the
Middle East, further we have
extremists c people of [ __ ] lapping the campaign
this is for peaceful protests bursting with
stormy harmony in social mirages both just at the peak
demands guilt in Ukraine a lot of jail
time threatens for spreading publications on the
Internet that contain
information of an extremist and
terrorist orientation  this
young man on his page on
social networks published information
containing the ideology of terrorism; there
were public calls
for extremist
activities, including methodological
publications on tactics to counter
law enforcement officers
during unauthorized
organized rallies and mass protests, as well as the commission of terrorist acts, a gesture of goodwill, a whole machine-like view of the feet of Russians all over the blood of the paraska, I would also like to recall that after Istanbul, in response to the sprouts of realism in the Ukrainian position, our armed forces conducted a deployment in the Kyiv Chernihiv direction in as a gesture of goodwill, a preemptive strike prices are equipped in a tornado on the territory of ukraine a preemptive strike on the position of the pins the position now the hands of the cubes we attacked here in this situation we are behaving some yes this is called a preemptive strike russia gave a preemptive rebuff sin or maybe bases and call them c90 after all, weaving in the civil infrastructure of mariupol, the topic would be you will live la vespa ore and sloping bottles, whether carnies and theaters and.  this
maternity hospital has long been occupied by the
Azov battalion and other radicals, from where they drove out
all the women in labor, all the nurses in general, all the
attendants, it was the base of the
ultra radical Azov battalion,
shelling,
but the maternity hospital was
liberated
from c strong opponents in some kind of
priming brought de hydrobots on it
despite the absence of a massive
reduction in  in a number of industries there is a
local optimization of costs associated
with the release of workers there is no
sustainable shortage of medicines meaning a
shortage already I both axis 8 st they
broke out riots began unrest c
meaning people went to methane and
ukraine with new forces the descent of my unrest in the
Donetsk region in a month will be one of the
largest  industrial cities of the country
Mariupol smoke thermo.
later, smoke sounded followed by a loop
ignition of the wiring today in the
morning there was a message about
smoke belgorod com hypermarket
line on queen street visitors and
employees
were evacuated
[music]
or a hectare in and the handwriting on them always teach
you you fell for censorship yes for defense
speak the truth in  on the Internet of the moon
to talk about the protection of children on the Internet the
federal law on the protection of children, it
is called so on the protection of children from
information that
is harmful to their health and development,
this law defines what is
harmful information at the beginning of this week,
Russian supervision blocked
instagram social networks
instagram and facebook in Russia  recognized as
extremist and banned their
activities on the territory of Russia
Russian Internet instead of the world
proposes to create deputies in the State Duma a
bill has been submitted so that the
Russian segment of the Internet can
continue to work even if it is
cut off from the world network
[music]
peacekeepers saviors free
Russian risky
officers in the compartment are going to cook, they are getting ordinary
Ukrainians
after the shelling of the bridge, though they didn’t get into the house
, and I’m writing, they said that Navalny should be
taught to free us from evil spirits, as if
we had emotions for months, I’ll order myself came,
we want to tell you, like,
treat those casums, I won’t demand it, the
neighbors  so there is a block on and the most popular
glory of you so new you and the dolls in the
Russian Federation from the male
unofficially still find out it feels there is an
option this is according to the account of someone hanging in the
comments and what our
collaboration with ukraine
erta was worthy of them
available for meeting
dad